en directo América vamos a hacer un
repaso por lo que titula la prensa
internacional en esta revista de prensa
y para ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañera Marta Moya Marta bienvenida
Buenos días Valentina bienvenida también
a ti muchas gracias muy importante vamos
a abrir esta Crónica esta revista de
prensa con los reportes del Wall Street
journal sobre la apelación fallida de la
defensa de uno de sus periodistas
estamos hablando de Evan girlscovich
arrestado en Rusia y quien parece que
por lo menos por esta temporada va a
seguir tras las rejas Pues si Valentina
apelación denegada nuevamente a Ivan
girlscovich un periodista que recordemos
fue arrestado a finales de marzo por las
autoridades rusas por presunto espionaje
Aunque Rusia no ha aportado mayores
pruebas de estos delitos por los que se
le acusa al periodista las autoridades
rusas dicen que el periodista deberá
seguir en prisión al menos hasta que se
celebre una siguiente vista y que la
prórroga va a seguir vigente porque Iván
George no puede en estos momentos volver
a Estados Unidos las autoridades rusas
como decíamos no han aportado pruebas
sobre esta detención y Estados Unidos
considera el arresto de gearscovich como
arbitrario e injusto la semana pasada de
hecho se firmó una resolución unánime en
el congreso de Estados Unidos para
exigir su Liberación aunque esto pues no
tenga mayor impacto sobre lo que haga o
no Rusia la vista en la vista estaban
presentes sus padres que abandonaron la
unión soviética en 1979 y que
recientemente han vuelto a Moscú Para
apoyar a su hijo en todo este proceso
judicial
deberá pasar en la cárcel hasta al menos
del 30 de agosto que es cuando expira
esta siguiente prórroga y según el Wall
Street journal los expertos dicen que
está bueno está estadía en prisión
probablemente se va a alargar durante
meses Porque tanto Los Fiscales como los
investigadores tienen
bastante Libertad para seguir ampliando
las prórrogas además dicen que
prácticamente todos estos casos acaban
en sentencias condenatorias por lo que
el corresponsal periodista del Western
journal podría enfrentar una pena de
prisión de hasta 20 años dada la
incertidumbre Estados Unidos ha pedido a
las autoridades el acceso consular de
Iván y hoy el viceministro ruso de
asuntos exteriores ser gay ha dicho que
Rusia está considerando este extremo lo
más posible para girlskovic según
destaca este artículo tanto del Western
journal como de al arabilla es que
gerskovic quede liberado bajo un canje
de prisioneros pero que esto no se dará
según funcionarios rusos antes de que se
emita una sentencia pues estaremos muy
pendientes al respecto Marta vamos a
cambiar de tema porque el medio de
investigación propublica a difundido una
investigación en la que afirma que uno
de los jueces de la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos
recibido obsequios no declarados por
parte de un empresario ligado al partido
republicano que tuvo casos frente a esa
corte Así es Valentina nos referimos al
juez de la Corte Suprema estadounidense
Samuel alito que compone no una de esas
sillas de la corte uno de esos nueve
asientos Pro pública este medio de
investigación dice que al hito en 2008
se alojó en un Resort de pesca de Alaska
que cuesta unos mil dólares la noche ahí
se tomó una fotografía con un
multimillonario de fondos de inversión
de alto riesgo llamado paulsinger que
está asociado como donante del partido
republicano según esta investigación El
Magnate también habría pagado el vuelo
en Jet privado hasta Alaska que habría
costado unos 100 mil dólares Todo esto
es muy controvertido evidentemente
porque Paul Singer tuvo al menos 10
casos ante la justicia estadounidense
concretamente ante la Corte Suprema Y
bueno pues aquí lo que se especula es
que si hubo conflicto de intereses y
cohecho Y si la relación personal entre
ambos influyó en las decisiones que tomó
Samuel alito ante la Corte Suprema
además se revive la polémica que ha
habido de los últimos meses sobre si los
jueces de la Corte Suprema tienen que
declarar todos los obsequios que reciban
por parte de donantes o de otras
personas hace unos meses ya hubo otro
escándalo asociado a otro de los jueces
de la Corte Suprema en este en este caso
Clarence Thomas también acusado de
recibir regalos por parte de otro
donante del partido republicano puro
República pidió explicaciones a Samuel
alito que no las contestó sin embargo sí
que publicó un artículo de opinión en el
Wall Street journal contestando a las
peticiones de propublica y negando todo
lo que le acusa esta investigación por
otra parte el portavoz de Singer dijo
que el multimillonario no organizó ese
viaje que no sabía que iba a ir el juez
a ese viaje a Alaska y que la relación
entre ambos nunca ha estado permeada por
los asuntos comerciales Bueno vamos a
seguir en Estados Unidos varios reportan
las fallas en la legislación sobre
donación de cuerpos a la ciencia esto
tras un escabroso escándalo que implica
al ex gerente de la escuela de Medicina
de la Universidad de Harvard sí
Valentina un tema muy escabroso y vamos
a ver un poco de contexto porque esto
implica a cedric ex gerente de la morgue
de la Universidad de Harvard que ha sido
acusado junto a su mujer y otras dos
personas de comprar y vender restos
humanos robados se les acusa de delitos
de Conspiración y Transporte
Interestatal de bienes robados y podrían
enfrentar penas de prisión de hasta 15
años
lotch supuestamente habría tomado
cabezas cerebros piel y huesos de cara
de cadáveres donados a la Facultad de
Medicina y los vendió por internet ha
compradores de Pensilvania y de
Massachusetts un esquema que habría
funcionado entre el año 2018 y el año
2021 lo que dicen los fiscales es que el
lotch se habría bueno beneficiado de su
como gerente en el programa de
donaciones atómicas para desmembrar
cadáveres y después venderlos por partes
otro detalle muy escabroso de esta
historia Valentina es que uno de los
compradores era una mujer que tenía una
tienda de muñecas hiperrealistas y que
quería curtir las caras de esos
cadáveres para venderlas ahora a partir
de todo este escándalo la en sí y el
Boston glow dicen que los expertos
señalan que tiene que haber una
regulación mucho mayor de las donaciones
de cuerpos porque la hay de donaciones
de órganos pero no de donaciones de
cuerpos que han permitido este
escandalazo bueno escabroso por donde se
le mire desde el ángulo que usted lo
quiera poner Marta vamos a cerrar en
Taiwán cientos de padres y madres con
hijos en un jardín infantil esto en la
ciudad de nuevo taipei están denunciando
que los docentes los drogaron drogaron a
los menores es una información que tomó
peso después de que varios de ellos
dieran positivo en drogas psicoactivas
si vamos de escandalo en escándalo
porque es un caso que está en
investigación una escuela infantil en el
distrito de alta clase de baorem en la
ciudad de nuevo taipei dice no bueno que
hay profesores acusados en esta escuela
infantil de este Distrito por drogar a
los niños con jarabes adictivos para la
tos al menos ocho alumnos han dado
positivo por trazas de estas sustancias
psicoactivas entre ellas benzodiacepinas
que son Bueno un sedante químico los
niños habían experimentado cambios de
humor y calambres y los investigadores
piensan que podrían ser síntomas del
síndrome de abstinencia por estas drogas
por el momento Valentina Hay seis
detenidos la escuela está cerrada y se
enfrentan a una multa de más de 150.000
dólares ha habido protestas de los
padres por la mala gestión de las
autoridades locales sobre este tema y
esto podría recaer sobre el alcalde de
nuevo taipei que se quiere presentar a
las elecciones presidenciales del
próximo año Así que podría haber
consecuencias negativas para el líder de
la oposición bueno noticias que
claramente generan muchísima indignación
Marta a usted muchas gracias por toda
esta ampliación gracias